en cette fin d'après midi du 5 mai
dernier
éric masson était en service
il était en droit une fois son service
accompli de rentrer chez lui auprès de
sa famille
ce soir là éric masson débat rentrer
chez lui comme vous tous
face au pire ils donnaient le meilleur
commandant éric masson au nom du
président de la république et en vertu
des pouvoirs qui nous sont conférés nous
vous faisons chevalier de la légion
d'honneur et nous sommes avec perrine
merci perrine d'être là vous êtes femmes
de policiers porte parole des femmes des
forces de l'ordre en colère vous étiez
présentes à l'hommage aux policiers éric
masson il ya eu le drame de viry
châtillon le drame de rambouillet
maintenant le drame d'avignon
vous êtes mariée avec un policier
exactement policiers effectivement qui
était d'ailleurs spécialisée en maintien
de l'ordre qui maintenant est retourné
dans un autre service pour raison de
sécurité justement
donc effectivement à un drame qui
endeuille la police mais qui ne cessent
de s'accumuler aux autres
j'avais l'impression que soit de pire en
pire oui oui totalement on a de plus en
plus de menaces mais on a encore
découvert des tags absolument immonde
dans des halls d'immeuble sur des murs
avec les têtes des policiers m'a pris
trois cent mille dollars
avec aussi d'autres tags qui visent
directement le meurtre d'éric masson en
10 ans une balle pour erika qu'il
prochain en quoi donc effectivement
c'est c'est pire en pire et c'est de
plus en plus douloureux d'autant quand
vous avez vu combien de temps péri à moi
je suis pas marié à quand vous êtes avec
un policier je suis avec un policier
depuis trois ans 3 ans et vous avez
senti que ça devenait de pire en pire
oui vraiment oui vraiment parce que vous
avez des menaces tous les jours est-ce
que les menaces qui se passe à
l'intérieur de l'intervention c'est ça
fait partie entre guillemets du métier
du risque inhérent au métier mais tout
ce qui se passe derrière tout ce qui va
viser directement les familles ça c'est
pas maîtriser aujourd'hui
enfin peut-être que dans d'autres
générations vous êtes
et fier de dire que vous étiez fils de
flic aujourd'hui dans l'association on a
des enfants qui reçoivent des pavés
venus de l'extérieur de l'établissement
scolaire en les insultant de fils de
flic
aujourd'hui on se tait quand on applique
aujourd'hui à des femmes dans
l'association qui ont peur de se marier
parce que justement dans les bancs
municipaux vous devez donner le nom le
prénom la domiciliation et la profession
de votre compagnon donc aujourd'hui vous
avez une cible dans le dos que vous
soyez policiers en service hors service
même une famille donc effectivement
c'est de pierre entière c'est incroyable
a déjà ce que perrine il a été tuées
pour la seule raison qu'ils étaient
policiers et d'autres aussi on l'a vu
avec le drame de rambouillet également
ça vous ça vous fait peur à chaque fois
que votre mari par le matin ou le soir
pour aller travailler
vous savez quand un policier vous vous
dites il ne prend jamais le même chemin
pour aller au travail ou pour rentrer du
travail que quand vous avez des
fonctionnaires de police qui travaille
dans les réseaux ferrés et qui ne
rentrent pas en transport en commun pour
éviter de croiser les délinquants qu'ils
ont l'habitude d'avoir
quand vous avez des gendarmeries qui
sont caillassés que vous avez même des
individus qui arrivent à pénétrer dans
les logements de gendarmerie vous dites
que demain votre compagnon va pas
rentrer et c'est une auteure qui est de
plus en plus présente
là on avait un contrôle certes de
stupéfiants qui se passait très bien
d'ailleurs la femme qui était contrôlé
le disait elle même avait il avait le
sourire ils étaient courtois est
malheureusement un autre individu s'est
amené dans ce contrôle là parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'uniforme qui
dérange et récurrents il portait son
brassard et c'est ça qui l'a tuée au
jour dans votre mari en fils sont un peu
votre compagnon enfile son uniforme pour
vous ce fait ils viennent cible il
devient possible non seulement parce que
la l'uniforme et parce que est
d'ailleurs monsieur le premier ministre
l'a très bien a précisé lors de
l'hommage
on est policier h 24 il était policier
tout le temps avec ma sont arrêtés
schiste de policiers ils étaient frères
de policier c'est une famille dit police
il considérait même ses collègues de
travail comme étant de sa famille donc
effectivement ils ont une cible dans le
dos en permanence
que ce soit en uniforme et on a pu le
voir avec les différences d'attentats
terroristes
vous aviez eu en 2010 est à un attentat
terroriste qui visait des fonctionnaires
de police sur le parvis de notre dame de
paris jo c'est parce qu'il a fait cet
uniforme là vous avez eu cette agente
administratif
stéphanie qui elle aussi a été égorgé
parce que policière vous aviez aussi
xavier juges les policiers et juste
parce qu'ils portent cet uniforme et
qu'il était dans un fourgon de police
il a été tué donc effectivement c'est de
plus en plus récurrents et aujourd'hui
la menace ne vient pas uniquement des
terroristes mais bien bien uniquement
d'une haine qui grandissante à
l'encontre de cet uniforme faut pas
oublier qu'aujourd'hui on a encore des
publications notamment de certains
groupes radicaux islamistes qui dévoient
complètement la religion islamique et
qui aujourd'hui appellent à tuer des
policiers français et des militaires
français
juste parce qu'ils ont cet uniforme là
quand votre mari vous donne pas de
nouvelles quand vous voyez qu'il tarde
donc vous n'avez pas la voir est ce que
vous l'avez tout de suite une prune peur
une crainte qui était il soit arrivé
quelque chose c'est pas tant l'absence
de réponse de la part de notre compagnon
qui fait peur c'est la peur d'avoir un
numéro inconnu puis vous appelle et
qu'au bout du fil on vous dise
c'est le major c'est le commandant ou
madame on est désolé c'est les sapeurs
pompiers on n'a pas pu réanimer votre
compagnon donc effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui vous trotte dans la
tête de plus en plus c'est à ça me
trottait déjà dans la tête avant mais
maintenant c'est omniprésent
ah oui c'est moi c'est tout le temps
j'ai tous les numéros de ses collègues
quasiment gg numéro delà du service
je vais jamais tranquille en fait non
jamais jamais et puis aujourd'hui quand
on est responsable d'une association
comme l'est l'association femmes des
forces de l'ordre en colère aujourd'hui
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on compte des
morts et on compte des orphelins
aujourd'hui vous avez un père de famille
qui tu ne pourras plus amener ses
enfants à l'école quand je le précisais
sa soeur ou le premier ministre
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est une petite fille qui pourra pas
être accompagnés à l'école parce que
papa qui très certainement n'apprendra
pas à faire du vélo avec son papa et qui
demain se fera peut-être même insultée
parce que son papa était policier alors
que
la laddh pleurer très certainement
toutes les larmes de son corps je me
suis même dit que vu la vitesse à
laquelle les médias montrent annoncé la
mort d'éric masson la famille a
peut-être même appris le décès de
celui-ci
alors ce média et non pas par le fameux
appel contre tous alors aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous dites est ce que vous
avez envie de dire à votre compagnon de
faire autre chose non jamais moi j'ai
pas envie en tout cas c'est qu'aucune
mentir et vivent dans la peur restait
voilà ce que vous me dites que vous êtes
tout ans tracy que vous n'arrivez pas à
vous détendre préféré vivre avec ça moi
je préfère vivre avec la fierté d'être
sanofi qui la fierté de partager ma vie
avec un individu qui a décidé
d'embrasser les valeurs républicaines et
qui aujourd'hui se dit qu' il a pu
accompagner mineurs pour fuir de chez
elles devant un service social parce
qu'elle se fait taper dessus par ses
parents je préfère me dire que j'ai ce
gentil policier à la maison qui a décidé
d'aller arrêter
sept autres abrutis qui a volé encore un
téléphone portable ou même pire celui ci
qui a été chercher un pied à l'autre
bout du corps d'un individu qui avait
décidé de se suicider donc je vis avec
ce type de personne qui fait des
découvertes de cadavres qui accompagnent
des victimes et qui me dit bah
malheureusement procureur va pas suivre
j'ai la fierté total d'être avec une
personne qui a les mêmes valeurs que moi
et qui en plus de ça veut bien donner sa
vie pour protéger les français
et ça ça n'a pas de prix par contre lui
pense à démissionner on a déjà parlé
vous a déjà dit on veut je vais arrêter
je veux faire autre chose oui parce que
quand vous êtes payé 1500 à 2000 euros
pour risquer votre vie uniquement parce
que vous avez un brassard police au bras
ça vaut pas le coup
est ce que ça vaut le coup de ne pas
pouvoir embrasser vos enfants soir juste
parce que vous avez un brassard police
assure le bras c'est pas possible
effectivement là vous avez éric masson
qui a été tué parce qu'il était policier
s'est pas
lors d'une intervention qui à mal qui
s'est mal déroulé c'est pas des grands
bandits
qu'ils étaient en bonne track n'était
pas une circonstance véritable danger
des millions d'indiens il est parti en
intervention c'est une mission du
quotidien il pensait vraiment pas et
même ses collègues pensez pas un instant
qu'ils n'allaient pas revenir
non et on le voit bien avec le temps de
réaction de son collègue qui
effectivement atteint malheureusement
n'appelle pas le temps de tirer sur
l'individu qu'il est déjà en train de
fuir parce que c'est c'est bien ça le
problème vous aviez un contrôle tout à
fait classique a pas de raison d'avoir
une telle menace
sauf qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des gamins
parce que ce sont des gamins de 19 à 20
ans qui sont mis en cause dans cette
affaire pour l'instant l'enquêté dira
déterminera toutes leurs responsabilités
ou non mais vous avez des gamins qui
sont aujourd'hui mis en accusation pour
avoir tiré et tué un policier
c'est incroyable c'est innommable et
mois dernier je me dis mais c'est soit
de terrible pour la famille d'apprendre
ça en plus de sade que son enfant ait
mis en cause là dedans et une bonne
famille de flics quand on éduque nos
enfants comment est ce qu'on fait
comment est ce qu'on se dit bon bah on a
un enfant qui a plus ou moins de ménages
que ces gamins-là et ces gamins-là ont
tué votre papa rond ou aurait pu le tuer
c'est terrible with you en tête
policiers c'est plus que j'avais
maintenant un métier à risque et madame
par l'instant du salaire des policiers
pour moi une des solution c'est de
valoriser la dangerosité de ce métier
c'est pas normal que des hommes et des
femmes qui risquent leur vie au
quotidien pour protéger la nation pour
protéger les français gagne 1500 euros
par mois je suis désolé donc il faut
valoriser sa est mieux payé des
policiers je considère madame vos
témoignages et et est bouleversant est
ce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
enfants de parler des enfants de
policiers on m'a dit que les enfants de
policiers leurs parents leur disais à
l'école tu dis surtout pas que tes
parents sont policiers et même aux clubs
de sport quand ils s'inscrivent aux
sports sur tout mais un autre métier qu
aux policiers je vais vous donner notre
anecdotes encore dimanche alors que les
syndicats avaient décidé d'organiser une
manifestation autour du du commissariat
d'avignon pour pour se rassembler et
donner un dernier hommage à à l'ats eric
nous associations on avait aussi eu
cette volonté là et on s'est rassemblé
devant un commissariat à paris sur les
champs elysées et on lui a aussi rendu
hommage
pendant cette intervention là on
a eu un témoignage qui m'a mis
bouleverser un fonctionnaire de police
m'a dit que sa fille avait appris
seulement à 16 ans donc cette année
qu'il était fonctionnaire de police
depuis plus de vingt ans parce que
justement ce papa là avait décidé de ne
pas générer de peur dans son domicile
mais aussi qu'elle ne soit pas
considérée comme étant la fille du flic
et qu'elle ne soit pas traquer en raison
de sa qu'elles ne soient pas harcelés en
raison de sa parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
de plus en plus récurrents et vous dites
ce ballet saison quoi donc ça que ça
montre l'accumulation l'accroissement
dans la violence et et la radicalité de
certaines personnes des kia l'homo
police et c'est ça qui est terrible et
aujourd'hui je discutais avec une femme
gendarme qui me disait on est tellement
plus respecté que quand je vais voir des
délinquants que j'arrête tous les jours
et que je vois tous les jours parce que
les gendarmes sont très très proches de
la population - et quillan un bain de
sang mais dis donc on fait la belle dans
sa voiture perso et lui donne sa plaque
d'immatriculation vous dit
qu'aujourd'hui mais vous êtes une cible
par rapport à ça alors que rien derrière
y a juste un contrôle il ya juste les
gars vous mettez votre masque on baisse
la musique parce qu'il ya un peu de
tapage
non il ya cette volonté de faire peur et
de cette volonté de deux d'appuyer dont
la vie personnelle ans il commence à
penser que ça va être de pire en pire où
ça peut s'arranger
ça peut s'arranger si on donne les
moyens à chacun de pouvoir faire son
travail correctement que ce soit pour
les policiers avec des moyens matériels
humains financiers que ce soit aussi
pour protéger les familles avec un champ
législatif créé
dédié à cela mais aussi pour la justice
parce que c'est bien beau de vouloir
aggraver la peine encourue pour le refus
d'obtempérer si elle n'est jamais
appliquée ça ne sert à rien et surtout
si les magistrats sont complètement
débordés ça ne sert strictement à rien
il faut aussi penser peut-être un autre
réponse pénale pour des jeunes
délinquants et les stopper dans cet
accroissement là mais aussi faut penser
à une question d'éducation
parce que moi je vois des gamins de 19
ans là qu'ils ont bon en plus déjà eu
des des condamnations précédentes parce
que ça a été mentionné dans les médias
mais qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
ces individus là se sont radicalisées
dans leur chemin criminelle comment
est-ce qu'on ne passe du petit allez je
vais prendre un terme barbare shiteux à
un meurtrier de flics ou est-ce que où
est-ce qu'on n'a pas arrêter l'escaladé
dans la violence parce que c'est bien ça
où est la défaillance éducative où est
la défaillance en termes de respect de
l'autorité
moi j'entendais le ministre aujourd'hui
évoqué la peur il faut que la peur
change de camp mais moi je n'ai jamais
parlé pter fasse un policier votre beau
diable dans les polars ou pas dont il a
peur quand il part le matin oui mon
compagnon a peur quand tu pars le matin
mais la peur de parvenir il n'y a pas
peur d'intervenir intervenir c'est
nécessaire c'est important et ça fait
partie du métier et vous savez un
policier qui n'a pas peur et ça a déjà
été dit par madi biscuits petit c'est
qu'il devient dangereux un policier tu
as peur est un humain et on oublie
toujours l'humain dans le niveau